do you have full conversations with
yourself in the booth or do you record
each clone separately no we go straight
through a scene I'm I'm jumping back and
forth between the characters well you
know
Tech is doing something over here with
the controls Rick am I want something to
eat over here and cross has just lurking
in the corner and Hunter thinks maybe we
should maybe we shouldn't do it this way
and echo says well we should because
that's the right thing to do they're
just different people
that's they just feel different to me
and so I can just kind of jump back and
forth
um with the with uh under the guidance
of um of of the words oh you're so
talented like it's almost like do a
British accent right now I would be like
I can't
that's the gym I've been working out at
for quite a while back
[Music]
[Music]
Hi D how are you hey Ash good to talk to
you good to talk to you I always love
your background and your room it's great
thank you I love it too I I it gives me
energy it charges my my my enthusiasm
yeah I need your tips I need to
redecorate
um
coming back for season two finally here
finally upon us what are you most
excited for fans to see this time around
the thing I'm most excited about is
season two is even better than season
one that it has really interesting
different side roads that it takes you
on that all feel very Star Wars that
connects beautifully into the larger
structure of what's playing out with
Palpatine's rise and uh it really UPS
the stakes
um it's it's it's my favorite part is to
is to follow crosshair's journey and to
really deepen that character uh with the
trials that he is uh subjected to and
it's just such great storytelling
um it's not just the Innovative fun of
the spaceships and the battles and the
fights which are so beautifully executed
but it's also the the heartfelt story of
of the child growing up of the guys
trying to be dads and learning uh to to
deal with the with this wildly
challenging improvisational situation
that's flying out them and I really
think that everybody who's who's ever
seen any Star Wars is going to love
these guys and and
Omega and the whole thing even more
because I I I'm so impressed and and
just so in love with how much better it
is which I I wouldn't have been able to
believe unless I'd seen it but I've seen
it now and it's it's incredible we are
not the enemy
I need a Galaxy peace peace
was never an option yeah it's it's I
mean it's also just such a pivotal
moment in Star Wars in the history what
does that mean to you yeah I mean it's
it's it's fascinating to see uh
Palpatine's iron grip starting to close
and and then that you know under that
kind of stress you find out who you are
right and and they are finding out who
they are uh and in deciding of how
they're going to play it so it's not
just a matter of fighting battles
um or running missions or heists and you
certainly have all of that but it's the
more interesting part is what is my
place in this universe how do I how do I
connect into these things that are
happening that are coming from me one
way or the other so when do and where do
I plant my flag and and and and and how
do I bring along my family with this how
does how does the family deal with this
do we all stay together do some of us
leave do some of us come back how how
does that all play out it's um it's it's
all very very engaging and um and and
it's just it's such great storytelling I
just I just love it is asking you to
pick a favorite member of the bad batch
like asking you to pick your favorite
child well yes it is and last you know
last season I would have said wrecker
because I just I love his that he's
strong and he's open and and fun and he
can eat whatever he wants and I can't do
that anymore
but this season this season it's I I
think it might be Crosshair his journey
and what he goes through is really
heartbreaking
it's yours
[Music]
he's a tough Diamond of a character that
I think is is made even more clarified
and sharper and and more revealed in
this season and and it's a really
interesting uh story arc for who he is
and what he's going through and for me
uh for this season it's going to be
Crosshair
ah love that now since it is a new
season they're a little bit older do you
tweak the voices at all between seasons
uh there's no General tweaking other
than
um them just reacting to what's flying
at them
um
there's there's there's difference in
how they relate to Omega definitely
there they give her more trust they give
her more leeway and they listen more to
what she wants to do or thinks that they
should do
she's she just says we're going to do
this and you know that she means it and
and they're like well
she's uh the kid's really competent and
she's really bright and she has a point
I guess we'll go that way
and so it's it's fun to see her come
online with her status and Authority uh
with it within the group that that that
that that starts right out of the gate
so there are a lot of theories
favorite one that you've read so far
um I am unaware I am unaware of the
theories I'm sorry
um I'll give you a few so Crosshair will
be fully redeemed uh Nala say is
actually spearheading the Palpatine
cloning program
what will happen with Crosshair I can't
I can't say what will happen with
Crosshair but I will say this is that
Star Wars plays out in a moral Universe
there's good and there's bad and there's
consequences for the decisions that you
make and there's also room for
transformation and Redemption that is
Star Wars that is the that is the new
hope that is the optimism that is
ultimately at the end of the tunnel for
Star Wars so
um not speaking specifically of anything
that I have any knowledge of
just looking at what Star Wars is and
why people love it and why it speaks to
so many people that that ultimately it
all leads to a place that we want to be
interestingly like the Vets returning
like they don't have any benefits and
like what becomes it's just so
fascinating yeah it's real stuff that's
not it's not like fantasy disconnected
stuff I mean that's part of why it's
it's so affecting and so beloved I think
is that this feels real whether it's
just about
trying to raise kids in a family or I
mean I've had I've had soldiers you know
shake my hand and say thank you sir uh
me and my platoon in Afghanistan we love
the clones and I'm like just thank you
uh I'm just a voice actor but but but
these these stories that are told they
connect to people in very meaningful
ways and uh that tracks back to you know
George Lucas's uh you know Brilliance
and his good insight and creative um
um courage and then the writers uh that
that that create these shows that that
are that are so beautifully skilled and
daring and still Taking Chances until
still telling interesting varied stories
that that connect back into this larger
cannon that is uh the Star Wars that we
know and love yeah yeah I also think
that's why people gravitated towards and
or so much it just had so much like
scary reality to it and or I just I
think about and or a lot the two
monologues is what I call them there's
two monologues the elevator and then the
show down there at the end kill me
Take Me In
if you if you're an acting student it's
like there's a monologue there's an
actor there's there's
and and one that is earned right that uh
all the story up to it some of it's very
deliberate very quiet that's woven in
there that finally pays off into this
punch of a monologue and that's a as an
actor that's a real pleasure to see it's
really powerful and I love it
keeps getting better and better